نذهب معكم الى الشتاء طنطوره حيث يعود
مهرجان شتاء طنطوره هنا في العلا ليسعد
زواره بالعديد من الفعاليات الفنيه
والثقافيه المختلفه هو اول مهرجان موسيقي
ثقافي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن
لماذا يسمى بمهرجان طنطوره الاسم مستوحه
من الطنطوره هي ساعه شمسيه هرميه الشكل
اعتمد عليها اهالي العلا قديما من اجل
معرفه الوقت وتحديد انطلاق موسم الشتاء مع
دخول فصل الشتاء وموسم الزراعه هو الموسم
الرابع من المهرجان ويحفل بباقه غنيه من
الفعاليات الموسيقيه على مسرح مرايا
الايقونه او قاعه مرايا التي تتمتع
بواجهها هندسيه خلابه تعكس تاريخ العلا
وطبيعتها على كل حال المزيد في التقرير
التالي الذي ادناه
[موسيقى]
هذه اذن ساعه الطنطوره الطنطوره عباره عن
ساعه شمسيه بنيت من الطوب الطيني بشكل
هرمي اعتمد عليها اهالي المنطقه قديما
لمعرفه الوقت وايضا الاحتفال بدخول
المربعانيه فصل الشتاء بدا موسم الزراعه
[موسيقى]
ربط التاريخ القديم لساعه طنطوره من مئات
السنين الى احياء الحفل السنوي في كل من
الثاني والعشرين من ديسمبر والذي يعني
دخول المربعانيه ويعتبر الوقت الامثل
للزراعه حيث تم ربط المسمى الاشهر للساعه
القديمه طمطوره الفعاليات واقامه ايضا
مهرجان طنطوره اهم المواسم الشتويه من
خلالها وذلك باطلاق عدد من الفعاليات تحت
مسمى شتاء طنطوره بمحافظه العلا
[موسيقى]
يعود الى الشتاء طنطوره اول مهرجان موسيقي
ثقافي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ليسعد
زوار العلا بفعاليات فنيه وثقافيه متنوعه
[موسيقى]
باقه من اروع الفعاليات الترفيهيه الفنيه
والثقافيه الحفلات الموسيقيه للمع نجوم
الفن تقام في قاعه مرايا التحفه الفنيه
[موسيقى]
تنهض قاعه مرايا من الرمال مثل السراب
المرايا العاكسه التي تجعلها اكبر مبنى
عاكس في العالم وفقا لموسوعه جنس للارقام
القياسيه
من رمال العلا تنهض قاعه مرايا تحفه فنيه
تتربى الاوديه الصحراويه وترسخ الدوره
التاريخيه للعلا باعتبارها عن نقطه التقاء
الحضارات القديمه على مر القرون هي اكبر
مبنى عاكس في العالم وفقا لموسوعه جنس فهي
مكسوره ب
9,740 مرايا عاكسه تعكس مظاهر الجمال
والطبيعه الخلابه للمدينه منذ اعوام تمضي
العلا في طريقها لترخيص اسمها كمركز
الثقافيا عالمي يحتضن العروض الترفيهيه
والبرامج الفنيه والافلام والحفلات
الموسيقيه وكذلك اجتماعات العمل
والمؤتمرات
حتى حفلات الزفاف
استضافت القاعه عدد من نجوم الفن العربي
والعالمي الممثل الامريكي انجليزي طنطوره
والامريكيه لشاكيز في اول العام الماضي
واشهر مؤخرا وخلال ايام تصنيف حفلتين
للنجمه اصاله والنجم كاظم الساهر اما
المايسترو ايطاليا مغني الاوبرا العالمي
اندريا بوتشيلي فهو ضيف العلا الدائم يعود
في مهرجان شتاء طنطوره ليقدمه خامس حفلاته
في المدينه
[موسيقى]
يعني قاعه مرايا اصبحت معلمه من معالم
العلا وادعونا نتعرف اكثر على طبيعه هذه
القاعه والطبيعه الهندسيه لهذا المسرح كل
حال معنا هنا في الاستديو الخارجي للصباح
العربيه سيد مشعل المزيني مدير اداره
المرافق يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك استاذ مشعل مرايا اسم على مسمى
لماذا اختيرت المرايا لجدران هذا المبنى
الهندسيه
عن طريق الملكيه محافظه العلا سر اختيار
المرايا اتى تعكس الجمال وطبيعه همم منتزه
اشاره
دون التاثير على الطبيعه
طبعا تم استخدام ما يقارب 3,018 لوح ااه
مرايا عاكس صنعت محليا بمواصفات فنيه خاصه
تلائم طبيعه هذا المكان ااا
حاله الطقس كدرجه الحراره تحرك الرمال همم
[موسيقى]
يعني تقلبات الجويه في بعض الاحيان فهي
خاصه وراح تتحمل ان شاء الله يعني
بالتقلبات الجويه همم اه طبعا احنا نحاول
انه همم من المرايا نحافظ على استدامه
المكان من الجمال الطبيعي بدون التاثير
طبعا
وهذه المرايا الواجهات العاكسه دخلت
موسوعه جنس سعوديه
داخل هذا المبلغ
الجمال الداخلي لا يقل عن جمال خارجي اكثر
طبعا الناس شايفين الجمال الخارجي همم من
الداخل همم يتكون المبنى من مسرح ل 600
شخص تقريبا
بالاضافه الى قاعتين متعدده الاستخدامات
مطعم عالمي يقع في سطح المبنى تم استخدام
هذا المبنى اللي عده مناسبات رسميه وغير
رسميه همم
كان همم قمه دول مجلس التعاون او ما يعرف
بقمه العلا على حسب اللي انت كنت متواجده
المدينه وقتها بالاضافه الى
اجتماعات رئاسيه وزاريه عده
المناسبات الغير رسميه لحفلات الغنائيه
خلال الموسم
معارض فنيه وتشكيليه
[موسيقى]
طيب استاذ مشعل في اماكن عده
واماكن عده موجوده هنا في العلا لكن لماذا
تم اختيار قاعه مرايا في وادي عكار
بالتحديد همم تم اختيار منتزه اعشار
البيئي نظرا لما يتميز فيه هذا المكان من
خصوصيه صنعتها الطبيعه همم الجبال المحيطه
بالمنتزه همم
تعطي جمال فريد همم مع الكثبان الرمليه
الجميله بالاضافه الى المنتجعات العالميه
المتواجده بجانب مرايا المشكله يعني
تشكيله جميله في هذه المنطقه خاصه
[موسيقى]
واليوم يعني مثلا هل سيكون هناك تطوير
لهذا المبنى اضافات جديده
الشكل النهائي هو هذا اللي واضح اليوم
المبلغ طبعا
مع التطويرات في الداخل والتغيرات على حسب
الفعاليات اللي بتحصل داخل المبنى لكن في
الخارج هذا الشكل
طبعا هو تم يعني انشاء المبنى
خلال سنه ونصف همم يعتبر يعني وقت همم
قياسي في هذيك الفتره نظرا البدايه اللي
كانت الجميله
صراحه اذا اردت ان اذهب الى قاعه مرايا من
اي جهه يجب علي ان طاقه الصور لاخذ الصوره
المناسبه
من كل الجهات تقريبا حتى هيكون من اللي هو
خلينا نقول من الجهه الي حتى لو من
الهليكوبتر بتشوفني طبعا برضه مرايا يعني
احنا بنعمل حساب حتى التفاصيل الصغيره
اللي حتى من الاعلى
شكرا
اذا كانت هذه زاويه تتعلق بقاعه مرايا
التي ترتبط بالشتاء طنطوره سنكون معكم
ايضا في فقره اخرى في سياق صباح العربيه
هذا اليوم في يومه الثاني من العلا
وتحديدا من البلده القديمه
كل زوايا
انا ما رح اخذ صوره الا من دونك
شكرا نادين